this is a production of Cornell
University so as always we have our
guest on today so today Brad Park from
Rutgers University really happy to have
Brad on we're going to talk about some
tall fescue so maybe some traffic
tolerance of tall fescues I know those
are going in a little bit more and
sports fields up here so chat about that
but as always Frank will start us off
with a little preview well here we go
for those of us jonesing for baseball
can you hear me Carl yeah okay good
alright good for those of us jonesing
for baseball this might be what its
gonna look like when it comes back to
the United States
this is South Korean players now it
seems surreal to see such a thing so
just you know we're wrapping up about
ten weeks of doing this with you guys
now now that everybody's busy we're
gonna take a hiatus and let everybody
get busy to their work we hope that
these shows have been useful distracting
enjoyable fun educational all the things
that we've been trying to do and getting
us through the first part of this long
haul on this pandemic and and we're
really grateful for our colleagues like
Brad Park that have taken the time out
to join us for the fastest 30 minutes in
turf as we've started to count let's do
a little quick weather review we're
still behind and you know we heard again
on Thursday mornings we have the benefit
of hearing from our climate center
expert our key guy tano on our weekly
call very very early in the morning I've
been chatting to rich with rich Buckley
for 20 years now Brad on this call I
think you've been on it with us a few
times we're still well behind in fact we
were much warmer up north here than you
were down there to the south we're
starting to see ideal conditions from a
heat perspective to do weed control if
you're able to do weed control and again
I've said to school grounds people
without the students around this might
be a good time to ask for an emergency
exemption to make some broadleaf weed
control you know if you have a pesticide
license or if there's funds available to
do this this is one important part point
we've
a number of weeks ago that weedy fields
are not safe fields right the footing
that you get from these different plants
out there requires a safety intervention
and with out any or minimal exposure
there's opportunities now to maximize
that I'm not sure I'd recommend spring
as the best time fall is typically going
to be a better time but but if you're
doing it in the spring models and things
like this can be very useful it's
unusually dry now for much of us I think
we're starting to see some drought
stress we heard from Dave Chinnery this
morning on the left here
Oh Frank we lost your audio here mr.
priciple
how's that I can hear you now little
choppy but we'll see her all right how
we doing now good we're good okay it's
dry looks like it's gonna be dry we're
coming into some of the driest time in
the year you grown grass on sands gonna
be worse the heats building and we're
starting to see some heat stress
certainly in Central Jersey South North
Jersey and stop 215 interesting and a
little bit cooler by the water soils are
starting to warm up er fees low 16 upper
60 you can see everything's plugging
along
still not consistent warm right still
not consistent warm
alright topic for today hope my internet
holds out Brad is really the importance
of the right species and variety
selection for sports fields and
particularly with regard to traffic
tolerance now I've been very hot on
these hybrid things
Greg munch Shaw has been playing around
with this and they're finding that not
unlike what you've been finding in the
cool season grass arena that the
varieties that you use in these cases
matter
obviously the muta varieties are a
little bit limited Chris you're going
with maybe more cold tolerant ones but
in this case the bluegrass variety seems
to have a big impact on the performance
of this now Doug sold that just tweeted
this out last week that's had some
long-term stuff going on at the
University of Wisconsin looking at
different varieties and seeing that uh
uh you know variety makes a difference
at weeding instant color and on the
right here you have the Kingfisher
variety um let me see if I get this the
Kingfisher variety this is zero
fertilizer to fertile at two pounds and
four pounds and you can see the
impact that it has on we deenis in this
particular case and I know you've been
doing this work but traffic simulators I
think this is the ke it's not this super
well as we go through some of this work
I want to make sure you clarify it for
me what your use and so here's some old
work you did looking at Kentucky
bluegrass Azure some recent work done
with Kentucky bluegrass varieties and
one of the things I thought you
concluded here was really interesting
that seasons of traffic seemed to matter
so you also did uh you know and you
looked at different varieties here but
let's stop here for a second Brad and
and bring you into the conversation let
me go back so you can see my screen I
want to talk about this bluegrass study
first if you don't mind right so so talk
a little bit about this work and and
this bluegrass day to here let's start
with the different types of bluegrass is
that people can pick many might not be
familiar with the Rutgers way of
characterizing blue grasses that you
guys pioneered you know years ago let's
start with the different types of blue
grasses and then we'll get to the
seasonality of their traffic tolerance
so as far as the as far as the types I
think just a little bit of a review for
for everyone participating what
bluegrass
types involved is a characterization of
individual varieties or individual
experimental selections based on
previously was based on their kind of
their growth or performance
characteristics their appearance dr.
Josh Hoenig dr. bill Mayer have kind of
taken it to an additional level where
now they've they've introduced DNA
fingerprinting and genotyping into this
where they can look at individual
bluegrass
you know varieties experimental
selections and now
group them move them genetically but
it's and what is the what is the
significance of these of these
differences Brad let's start with their
differences relative to traffic
tolerance well I think what I think were
so important is from a from a blending
perspective where if you're going to put
you know two or more blue grasses
together to kind of improve the you know
the genetic diversity so to speak within
the blind it's important not only look
at individual varieties but also try to
select varieties across types so for
example the compact midnite types the
midnight types are a group of of
bluegrass Kentucky bluegrass so they're
actually very similar as far as the way
their growth or performance
characteristics very very slow to green
up in a spring they actually do have
very good summer performance they
maintain their winter color long into
the fall they have very dark green color
pretty good summer patch tolerance but
they are generally very very slow to
green up so not good for lacrosse in the
spring
I think petite well I think if it's a
very very early you know early season
lacrosse which is a is a difficult sport
to deal with it's just just just in
general but I think I just think the
expectation on the part of the part of
the turf manager has to be okay these
things are gonna grow you know these
things are gonna green up very very
slowly once they get going though um
they you know they they have good yeah
they're pretty pretty we're and traffic
tolerant and so one of the things that's
interesting to me is is what I think
Doug is getting at in some ways is that
newer varieties seem to be dependent on
being fertilized routinely more recently
developed improved low cut blue grasses
generally require more intense
maintenance and I'm willing to do that
Brad if I get more traffic tolerance is
there something there between the
common types like Ken blue or some older
ones that might actually be better for
where tolerance rather than some of
these new ones that will be better with
fertilizer but the old ones will be
better with minimal inputs do you see
what I'm getting at I I do I do I think
I think the one thing you've got to be a
little bit careful with some of the
older blue grasses is is susceptibility
to leaf spot particularly in the spring
and it's you know different than the
gray leaf spot that affects rye grasses
and you know an out tall fescue but that
that is a you know that is a challenge
with the can blues and some of the some
of the kind of the common types that the
susceptibility to the leaf spot caused
by Josh Lara by Polaris you know that's
that's that's a challenge with those but
I mean I I I think that you know they
they do persist yes you know they they
they do persist right they do persist in
fact the less you do the more they
persist right I I think one of the other
thing that just to add with bluegrass I
think the I think the establishment year
is is pretty critical and particularly
from a fertilization standpoint where
you know you got you really want to get
these things in the ground seeded you
know latter part of August through the
month of September and then you know be
maybe de vigilant use that term with
fertilization to just make sure that you
know you feel it and to get that canopy
canopy to fill in and I think as
bluegrass ages I I do think the you know
the the the N need does does does
subside but you know that first that
fall and then that subsequent spring I
think it's pretty important you know
what to to solo debug yet let me bug you
now to move on to the tall fescues and
then we're gonna bring them together in
the end
mixture right so you've also done
similar traffic work with the turf type
tall fescues and you know I review I
spend a couple of hours
you and some of your work before we get
together and this is the quote at the
very end of the paper that actually
struck me that sometimes the things we
select grasses for like dark blue green
and fine texture don't necessarily
translate to the functional performance
that we always want now this is work
from I think one of the international
proceedings from 2009 or 2009 anyway the
long and the short of it is have we
selected for a really good looking blue
grass tall fescue types and have we
sacrifice some traffic tolerance because
of it
I I think that the let me let me say
this about the the the the newest the
newest tall fescue trial that the 2018
test we initiated traffic last fall on
it and I actually just yesterday just
ran kind of a real basic correlation
between the quality ratings that I took
which when I rate for quality I I don't
put a real strong bias towards collar
for me it's more of a uniformity issue
it's it's a density issue and those
quality and traffic tolerance ratings
were were just as far as a linear
relationship they were linearly related
so you know the the quality relationship
again I think where the evaluator is
putting a premium on on things like
density and uniformity and then traffic
tolerance I I bet that relationship you
know is still there so you can touched
on so you've touched on the things that
are important for traffic tolerance and
somewhat aesthetic tolerance if you've
got a dense uniform turf independent of
the color it may be off-putting from a
greenness perspective but but ultimately
it's it's going to be more traffic
tolerant and in many ways our focus on
traffic tolerance keeps us safe right
there's some measure that that's a safer
field if it's dense in uniform right
Brad I I would agree I would agree I
think I think the you know just the
uniformity issue in and of itself where
you you know you're you're establishing
traffic tolerant you know varieties
cultivars right on species doing a good
job a species selection and you've got
it you know a uniform surface versus a
surface that's lack you know just
doesn't have the uniformity and I guess
you know let me follow up because you
really got yourself going there for a
minute on the establishment thing and I
think it's a key to some of the
challenges we have with both blue grass
and tall fescue and I have to say it
wasn't until you could get good tall
fescue bluegrass sod
that you started to see more tall fescue
into the landscape because it's not
something that we would recommend you
just put out there like you put out rye
grass because of the potential for non
uniformity in leaf texture right if
you're over seating a rye grass field
with tall fescue and it gets clumpy
that's going to be off-putting so the
ability to put these things together and
then sell it as sod is also something
that you've been looking at and again
we'll put links to a lot of this work
that people can follow up and and review
this yourself but you know your work
here with Murph on these combinations
it's very interesting because you know
Brown Pat severity is a weak link for
tall fescue and of course you you put
the more Kentucky bluegrass you put in
there it seemed to reduce the amount of
brown patch you've got but and I wonder
if you could explain this how did the
bluegrass variety impact the amount of
brown patch maybe a tall fescue variety
that was weakened it got was it the up
was it the percentage of bluegrass or
was there something about that cultivar
that kept a brown patch from getting
severe well I think it's what's really
important to recognize about this study
is that the the bluegrass cultivar
selection was really what governed
that's right the the performance of
these mixtures from a standpoint of
everything from brown pass severity to
speak composition and the two really
strong bluegrass is that we that we
investigated were blue note and midnight
too and those are those are very high
quality high-performing compact
Midnight's well blue note blue note is a
compact America type so it's it's
actually got a little bit a little bit
lighter color a little bit earlier green
up it's it's very quality variety
midnight to a little slower green up but
you know once it once it gets going you
know III think it's about as good as
as good as anything but we don't
associate brown patch typically with
Kentucky bluegrass do those also
separate out for brown patch ability
well I think what happened in that study
is that the you know the inclusion of
those cultivars you know they really
tended to dominate the tall fescues so
that that brown patch that we employed a
fairly complex statistical analysis in
the study but the the basically the
inclusion of those cultivars in the
mixes and as those bluegrass those
aggressive blue grasses dominated the
mixtures with tall fescue I think what
you were seeing from a brown patch
perspective was just the bluegrass
becoming any more predominant component
in the mixtures so is that what happens
to these sods if you put them in the
ground as you know the best ones are
planted what 90 10 in the field 90 tall
fescue 10 bluegrass they make it to the
field probably 50/50 in some cases maybe
more bluegrass than tall fescue you put
the sod down does it then just become a
bluegrass or does it also sometimes
become a tall fescue stand what our
research suggests is that that
transition over to bluegrass is going to
be a function of the bluegrass cultivar
selection now this guy kind of goes
against what we traditionally recommend
is you know agronomist and extension
people and always choose the best
variety the catch-22 so to speak of all
this is that some of these better blue
grasses while we want to use those when
they're mixed with tall fescue that
could facilitate that transition over to
a predominant bluegrass bluegrass
mixture so you know the question kind of
gets back to you know you were bringing
up some of these common types and so
forth you know do you if the goal is to
have as much tall fescue in that mixture
is the desire that that to be a long
time long term component of the mix do
you really
need a high-end Kentucky bluegrass
cultivar in that mixture you just want
something that is not going to perform
the role as being raised honest so
though that that song can be lifted and
then provides some insurance against
brown patch which we know tall fescue
has got you know there's a big challenge
there so so in some ways that bloom Yuda
idea is the same way that it feels like
these things are helping each other it
would through the season I guess what
I'm wondering is are we having issues
with sod growers using the weaker
bluegrass varieties because they
typically don't want to buy those
varieties for their bluegrass sod
I I think it's I think it's kind of all
over the map I mean on I there's there's
a facility that I'm familiar with that
that established a bluegrass they
purchased a sod bluegrass tall fescue
mixture the blue grasses were not
top-shelf blue grasses and there's still
a lot of tall fescue in the you know in
in the mix and you know from if the
objective of kind of having a tall
fescue turf and having it significant
pote of the turf bean tall fescue going
forward you know that makes that the
grower established you know it's
achieving that she's also how much is
gonna be related to what happens when
you put sod down Brad you know you lay
side down certainly you know comes
juiced
probably from the sod producers field
and then in a sports field you know they
always be let me get it going so he
given it some more in
and then I'm wondering how much that
always tends to favor the bluegrass over
the tall fescue what we've done on our
campuses we've strived to put more tall
fescue in we haven't paid as much
attention to the varieties they think
like you've said side growers we don't
always get the choices that we want
right that's one of the limitations
aside but we put it in and we don't
really do anything but mow it and
oversee tit and Arif I it once a year
over seed it just to get more tall
fescue in there and boy those have
become beautiful stance you can't barely
find the bluegrass in them they become
dominant tall fescue so how much does
the management then determine how much
tall fescue you're going to have
thinking that more firt means more
bluegrass is that logical I think it is
I think you know I think anything a
higher cutting heights and you know less
nitrogen you know lower kind of annual
nitrogen quantities lower you know just
less frequent irrigation and I mean
anything that's going to you know kind
of it's going to provide the tall fescue
an advantage you know it's got a it's
got it's got to help
you know I think having the control over
kind of what you're doing if you have
the opportunity to establish for a
feeling for the first time and you can
you know you can really drill down on
that seating rate maybe even want to go
to lay nearly a a ninety-five five
ninety five percent tall fescue five
percent Kentucky bluegrass
bye-bye-bye wait you know that you know
I think is another you like that you
like that strategy i I think it's I
think it's worth giving it a shot you
see do you see that kind of do you see
those things available that's one of my
questions on my list I mean you and I
can talk out the kazoo about this
variety that variety and the varietal
differences within a species can be as
big as the differences between the
species right uh you know tall fescue
varieties within a tall fescue can be as
different as tall fescue and Kentucky
bluegrass species so I don't do you find
a lot of ninety-five fives on the
marketplace it may find seed companies
willing to work with us on this I I
don't I don't see a lot of it doesn't
mean it doesn't exist but I don't how do
you decide how does somebody decide is
it season is it maintenance how would I
decide if I'm starting out whether I
should have a bluegrass or tall fescue
field or go with that blend I'm gonna
put you on the spot of how you get about
deciding what to go with if this whole
thing allows you to do some renovation I
think first of all having a having a
discussion about what the anticipated
management inputs are going to be going
going forward so you know I think if you
know if the objective is lower you know
fewer nitrogen inputs less irrigation
going forward a higher cutting height
you know I think
you know I think a tall fescue bluegrass
mixture and I think having the bluegrass
in there it does provide a little bit of
a little bit of an insurance policy
particularly on the particularly on the
brown patch issue here and here in
central New Jersey because that that's
that's a legitimate legitimate concern
you know but it's let's say a school
municipality new construction project
they wanted to go for seat you know you
wanted to start something from seed and
even with automatic water but if they
were trying to be you know minimalist
with it yeah I would I would probably
push them in towards uh you know Prague
towards it towards a 90/10 alright hey
Carl questions for Brad
yeah a couple comments Ben was just
mentioning he said great Ben polymer
Massachusetts have you've had great
success with mixtures of no more than
60% turf type tall fescue and then again
he was echoing the need for high-end and
establishment so really important for
him that establishment phase great joy
this is challenging you guys even
YouTube heavy hitters can't convince me
tall fescue on athletic fields he's used
it he doesn't like it nothing like KBG I
guess some you know the question I want
to ask is that you know sometimes we
talk about clumpiness of tall fescues
and when we achieve draw on a couple
weeks ago talking about player safety he
was talking about how uneven this and
the surface can provide safety concerns
when an athlete expects maybe their foot
to plant in one way and if the earth is
clumpy and it goes a little bit their
foot travels a little further down that
could present a safety concern anything
from you Brad and the concerns with the
clumpiness and the tall fescue and maybe
not being something of a safety concern
well I think I think part of the part of
the issue with clumpiness we could
probably spend a whole call on this you
know I think it does get back to
establishment where if you if you don't
do a good job establishing tall fescue
for the first time and you get
everything from seed washing to
insignificant you know in insufficient
seeding rates and you just don't have a
critical number of plants out there that
right off the bat is gonna leave a
clumpiness
I mean with this this actually this is
background that the Franks
using over there kind of on the far side
beyond where we covered we had some
washing and we you know it's not part of
the test it's part of a bore area but
that still hasn't filled in and that's
going on back in 2018 so you know tall
fescue yes there's some rhizomatous you
know attributes but it's but it's
basically functionally I think it's a
bunch type grass it's not like Kentucky
bluegrass the way Kentucky bluegrass is
: so III I think some of the clumpiness
can be overcome with against seeding
rates seeding timing making sure you get
enough get enough get enough plants out
there
I think the species as an athletic feel
look I don't think it's for everybody
but I mean we've got a couple school
districts here in New Jersey you know
kind of south of the New York metro area
that are that are enormous and these
high school middle school kind of group
complexes no irrigation you know they've
got limited limited you know labor and
you know they've gotta mow it to two and
a half inches they don't even actually
have access to water reels and that's
where you know tall fescue is is a good
choice given you know the some of the
the summers that we have the warmer
climate you know kind of northern
transition zone and you know that that
to me where we're not talking about real
high in sports here you know we're
talking about middle school sports um
high school sports practice fields and
so forth where you know III think it
makes I think it makes himself and I
gotta say and I'm gonna make one more
shot at it Greg
you know I travel and visit golf courses
in the mid-atlantic and they have
embraced tall fescue fully in the rough
you see some beautiful tall fescue in
the rough when you get into the
mid-atlantic I know Brad can attest to
it as well now on a sports field I think
I would always agree with Brad that I'd
want Kentucky bluegrass as a base I just
think having a rise ominous base on a
sports field is a functional aspect of
that field that you can't replicate with
any other species that you'd want out
there so there's no question
about the fact I don't want any sports
field that's going to plant a cleat in
it that doesn't have some rays ominous
bluegrass in it
I think call fescue gives us a wider
latitude of management that I can do I
could you sit up and get what I want in
the density I think I can cut it lower
and then I if if I don't and I'm a
little bit more light I think I have
some flexibility but I do think what
Brad said about warmer right blue
grasses have struggled in the heat
historically there's ones that are good
in the heat but they maybe are not as
good in the shoulders of the season
right Brad I mean I think that's the
argument where bluegrass might not
always be the answer if if the shoulders
of the season traffic might be what you
need why I think certainly in the you
know in the spring and I think the
shoulder seasons are just you know
they're they're just a challenge across
the board you know and and you know it's
it's March it's it's it's the end of
it's the end of October and you know
that's where that's where it to me
traffic management becomes important
trying to kick in you saw it I mean can
you find an avenue to sod at some point
you know after you know after November 1
or November 15 and work with
administrators to kind of close the
field down okay look we're done November
first we're gonna we're gonna sod
between the hash marks we're gonna saw
down the center and I mean we can
ryegrass oversee dry grass oversee dry
grass oversee but you know being able to
come in and and so that's where
bluegrass you know make makes a lot of
sense I mean if that's what the you know
you know sod with blue over seed with
rye but I think there are situations
again we're you know in the absence of
irrigation and you know establishing a
field for the first time you know I
talked I mean I could work with a I'd
work with a guy that just swears by it
[Music]
you know doesn't want to touch a rye
grass because you know he's afraid it's
not gonna survive the summer and you
know they don't think they can't really
do a lot of sodding so
and that's why last year when the gray
leaf spot took the tall fescue out that
got very concerning cuz you know that's
the kind of thing that changes the game
if all of a sudden these low maintenance
areas with higher cut tall fescue or
having problems with great leaf spot you
know that that was a very scary thing
when you know Bruce Clark a for Bruce
Clark's lawn dies because a great leaf
spot everybody gets nervous right Brad
yeah I think I think that's an emerging
concern I think it's gonna be
interesting to see how great leaf spot
and tall fescue kind of affects you know
new plantings versus you know older
established plantings you know and I
don't know I'm not at least here you
know New Jersey and North that were
really know enough about it at this
point but I mean which sits on the radar
for sure and one of the out of this 2018
tall fescue tester there is a new one of
the newer variety there just like on
commercial and the name actually is kind
of marketing itself as they is a gray
leaf spot you know tolerant tolerant
yeah new a new tall fescue 12s alright
Carl more questions are we good I think
there's a lot of great comments from you
know band and grain and dance a chipping
in there too so I'm really happy to have
a conversation I think that's about a
half an hour please end it Brad thanks
for taking the time it's always great to
chat with you I really appreciate you
being patient with my long questions and
putting you on the spot but I don't
think we think about varieties a lot and
some of it is to be honest this it's not
a lot of good seedsman left out in this
industry I just don't see the seedsman
the same way I used to so thanks for
being that resource for us and I hope
that everybody there as well and Rutgers
is keeping you safe now I appreciate the
opportunity and hey you know anytime we
can talk about you know using data and
looking at data to make to make
decisions I think that's excellent you
know that's what it comes down to thanks
a lot thanks Carl signed off now to
we'll see you again sometime yeah well
let everybody know either through a
shortcut newsletter or Twitter or a
website will post whenever we're ready
to do another one
maybe maybe in a month or so but we'll
see so we'll let you guys know thanks a
lot thanks Brad
Thank You Frankie like Harlem yes this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu